I need your help
everybody is Charlie we have the best
possible news ever
live-action spider-verse is apparently a
thing going on behind the scenes at Sony
something that they're planning so I'll
break down what's going on they were
doing spider-man far from home press so
naturally that's where we learn about
all this big stuff that's happening if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos
spider-man far from home is dropping
next week we're doing an IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so big thing
first obviously they're doing the
animated spider-man into the spider
burst movies they're developing the
sequel for that right now they'll
probably keep making those movies they
have a bunch of spin-offs plan like
spider-gwen they're talking about making
other animated spin-offs and then Sony
obviously has all of its venom and
spin-off venom verse movies going on to
in the side I could use someone like you
on my world I'm sorry you world from
just not ours
there are multiple realities Peter this
is earth dimension six one six I'm from
Earth 833 we share identical physical
constants level four symmetry
I'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse because I thought that was
just theoretical I mean that completely
changes how we understand the initial
singularity BC so the Saudi people were
talking about live-action spider-verse
Kevin Feige was also talking about venom
crossing over with spider-man so we sort
of clarified where Marvel is on all this
and where Sony is on all this and how
it's all going to go down any chance
there's a multiverse in which Andrew
Garfield spider-man until McGuire
spider-man and spider-man all meet
together would you want that do we want
that
think about this filming right you take
spot amount of Europe and what's so cool
about that is you've never seen
spider-man in Europe now of course I'd
[Music]
like Kevin this is what we're doing on
the next one but it would be first
things first Kevin Feige clarified this
Sony was the one that would be
developing the venom spider-man
crossover so he made it sound like there
were no plans to bring venom
to the MCU anytime soon so venom
probably not gonna have anything to do
with spider-man 3 in Marvel seems like
it's building its spider-man movies to a
much different logical endpoint than
Sony is going forward with its venom
spider-man movies so that means that
when spider-man eventually down the road
crosses over with venom it'll probably
be Tom Holland crossing over into a
venom movie instead of venom crossing
over into an MCU spider-man Tom haulin
movie that also means that little
further off then venom spider-man
live-action spider-verse would also be a
Sony creation they would be the people
developing that they owned the
spider-verse franchise in the animated
universe right now it's pretty easy to
assume that Kevin Feige would just let
them attempt that on their own there are
a lot of really weird technicalities
about the sharing arrangement with the
spider-man character because it seems
like Norman Osborn is gonna become a big
MCU character soon the kingpin really
big spider-man villain has also been an
MCU character recently and it seems like
he'll continue to be so wherever he pops
up again in the MCU but the reason why
venom vs. spider-man is probably going
to happen first is because right now
they have Tom Hardy under contract as
Sony and they have Tom Holland under
contract at Sony so there's no extra
wrangling it would take to get those two
together so after spider-man 3 is when
I'm expecting them to actually try venom
vs. spider-man so this is a good three
to five years down the road just for
that then if that seems to work out then
that's what they would try live-action
spider-verse
so we're talking you know good six to
seven years before they try something
like that
so Sony's end point for these spider-man
movies would be something like spider
verse or spider Geddon which is sort of
the infinity war version of a spider-man
crossover with just spider-man
characters the test for that though
because Sony is already doing these
animated spider-man into the spider
burst movies is is crossing all the
different spider-man Tom Holland Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield over in the
animated movies first to see if they can
get it to work if you don't remember
when they were doing press first
spider-man into the spider verse last
year Phil Lord and Chris Miller the
producers did say that they wanted to
get
toby mcguire and andrew garfield to
guest star as characters in it but just
decided to hold off for potential
sequels we don't really talk about this
they recently started working on that
first sequel so don't be surprised if
you hear at least one more familiar
voice in it like wait a minute that
sounds like Tobey Maguire voicing that
other spider-man character but right now
that's minimum two to three years off
just because it takes a little bit
longer to make those animated movies
than it does the live-action movies they
also talked about incorporating
live-action elements into the first
spider-verse animated movie but decided
it was just a little too crazy the funny
thing is is that if you remember the
intro from that movie when they were
doing the Chris Pine version of
spider-man there were a couple
live-action elements that they
incorporated into the montage look I'm a
comic book I'm a serial did a Christmas
album look worse but through Amy Pascal
the Sony people were saying that we
support the idea of live-action
spider-verse it's just so far off down
the road that obviously they're not
gonna put a date on it and they're more
focused on venom vs. spider-man in the
venom sequels right now when it comes to
Tom Hollands spider-man that's mostly
Kevin Feige MCU stuff they're mostly the
ones handling the developing of that
universe they also clarified that the
venom sequels in the venom spin-offs
because they're doing the Morbius movie
they're also developing a Kraven the
hunter movie they're developing a black
cat movie those will all be on their own
like they're not immediately going to
crossover with venom or with Tom
Hollands spider-man it'll all be
considered in its own universe and then
maybe down the road if they want to
cross them over then they'll try it when
they get there so that also probably
means that we won't see black cat
popping up in any of the spider-man MCU
films either but a lot of you're saying
what's gonna happen when they try to get
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield to
come back and play their versions of
spider-man because think about it this
way Andrew Garfield will be in his 40s
by the time they get something like that
early 40s in Tobey Maguire will be in
his early 50s when they would get to
something like that that's an old
version of spider-man but the really
cool thing is is think about Aunt BAE in
the spider-man movies the youngest
looking version of Aunt May that we've
seen in a movie they even said that they
were treating the character
as if she was more like Peters big
sister during Captain America Civil War
obviously a couple of years have gone by
so she's a little bit older by now
talking a little bit of story Tobey
Maguire would be Prime Uncle Ben age I
mean it'd be a younger version of Uncle
Ben so if you wanted to kill off a
version of spider-man during a big
spider verse live-action crossover he
would be a prime candidate and even then
if they actually do get to it I think it
would probably wind up being a one-off
thing just because it'd be so hard to
get those actors to come back and if you
wanted to do a follow up spider get in
live-action movie you would probably try
to look to other versions of spider-man
to crossover Tobey Maguire has always
spoken highly of Tom Hollands version of
spider-man since he debuted in Andrew
Garfield hasn't said a whole lot about
it I'm just really excited to just be a
fan again as opposed to but he did talk
about his time as spider-man it's kind
of heartbreaking to hear him talk about
it because there's this clip where he
talks about how he feels like he never
quite nailed the character of spider-man
but I think the something that there is
something that happens in those I don't
know if what your experience was but my
experience there's something that
happens that something that happened
with that experience for me where it was
story and character were actually not
top of the priority list ultimately
yeah and I think that's I found that
really really tricky I signed up to
serve the story and so this incredible
character that I've been dressing at
since I was three yeah and then there's
the it gets compromised and I and it
breaks it breaks you praise my heart no
I got my god broken a little bit to a
certain degree not entirely there were a
lot of people that were wondering how he
felt about Sony after all this went down
because they didn't really call him when
they were recasting for Tom Horne he
learned that he wasn't spider-man
anymore when Sony made the public
announcement that Tom Holland had be
cast as spider-man for Captain America
Civil War like I guess that means we're
not making amazing spider-man 3 anymore
and I'm out of a job as much as he got
burned by that he did that funny Kimmel
prank as spider-man just a little while
after that so that just lets you know
that he's taking it like a champ and is
all water under the bridge so I don't
think that there would be any issues
with him coming back as long as the
script was really good but this is that
clip
[Applause]
[Music]
so if Tom Holland wants to do it the
studio Sony wants to do it in the actors
are willing to come back and they find a
good enough script we will definitely
see live action spider purrs at some
point but like I said timeline
realistically is six to seven years so
everybody as long as you just stay alive
to watch it you'll get it eventually in
some form or another because of all the
spider-man far from home stuff happening
this week if they do announce anything
about the spider-man into the spider
burst animated sequel I'll do a separate
video about that because they're gonna
get way crazier than the animated movies
way faster than they would in the
live-action movies there were a bunch of
Comic Con announcements for Marvel and
DC recently so I'll have a couple videos
coming up this week my full review of
spider-man far from home will post next
week after the film drops in and I'll do
Easter eggs in a post-credits scene
video but leave all your video requests
in the comments below congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video Isaiah Holland please email
me on the about page of my channel so I
can get your details click here for my
thor guardians of the galaxy three
teaser video and click here for my
non-spoilery spider-man far from home
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you